okay so I've got some title ideas for
the next spider-man film that's great
can't wait to hear oh well you know how
everyone features some play on the word
home I think these are gonna be right on
brand well then go on let's hear them
picture this
spider-man home wrecker where Peter
cheats on MJ oh wow well that's
upsetting because they just got together
and they're not married and they don't
have a home I hear you loud and clear
how about this spider-man
homebound Peter Parker develops terrible
agoraphobia pretty hard to fight crime
when you won't leave the house people
know who he is now
maybe it makes him nervous well I guess
that makes sense what else were you
thinking how about this one then
spider-man whole mom the range it's a
Western gunslinger meets webslinger ooh
dangerous and sticky I like it all right
well how about you try this one on for
size
spider-man home alone where instead of
using his fighter powers he instead sets
creative traps using everyday household
objects eat paint can Hobgoblin aw and
then finally we have one that I know
you're gonna love spider-man home for
the holidays a nondenominational
celebration for the entire family well
I'm sold
call up the boys we've got ourselves
something to announce at Comic Con
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
using our theorist tingle to dispel all
of Mysterio's illusions and let me tell
you between fake restaurants fake
Mysterio's and fake nick fury's I was
tingling all over the place while I was
watching far from home probably should
get that one checked out by a doctor but
seriously I felt like I couldn't trust
anything the ushers were in there trying
to pry me out of my seat and I'm like no
I feel the barf drones around me you're
all just trying to make me think the
movies over but we're still somewhere in
act 2 long story short I'm not allowed
in that theater again on the plus side I
left far from home with a heck of a lot
of theory fodder so today I'm tackling a
theory that is so speculative it's more
hypothesis than theory I know I know
blasphemy but coming out of the theater
I couldn't get out of my head and I
thought it was a cool topic to talk
about on the series you see the most
important part of far from home isn't so
much what's in the movie it's instead
what's coming after the movie far from
home isn't just another step in Marvel's
stairway to box-office heaven it's clear
that this movie is acting as an
inflection point between where we've
been and where we're going a gateway to
the post endgame era of Marvel where
everything is suddenly being called in
question from your leadership to your
very identity and as a part of that I'm
here today to predict spider-man's next
major role in all of it because at this
point the Tom Hollands spider-man movies
have tipped their hand just a bit too
far I think they've revealed just a wee
bit too much and as a result I have a
solid hypothesis as to where things are
headed for the old webhead in the next
feature film so book your tickets now
ladies and gentlemen because
spider-man's next opponent will be a
massive showdown with the sinister six
for those of you who might not be
familiar the sinister six is a team
consisting of a number of spider-man's
nastiest villains can you guess how many
usually a massive team-up of super
villains would be something that would
develop pretty late into a comics career
as they figured out how to come up with
new exciting storylines for the same
character but when it comes to the
sinister six their beginnings actually
start as far back as the beginning of
spider-man comics themselves back in
1963 and since that time there have been
no less than
four different versions which have had
names like the sinister six the sinister
seven the sinister 12 the superior six
the hexagon of haters the six most
sinister and the six men of synastry
that hexagon one was a joke by the way
but it's not like you could tell right
this group's gone through more reboots
than the spider-man movies have but in
all seriousness me standing here as my
virtual cutout saying that the films are
gonna feature spider-man's most iconic
villain group probably isn't gonna be
set in the world on fire so instead
let's get even more specific by picking
out who exactly those six characters are
gonna be that would be a little bit more
impressive right I mean I need to do a
lot of making up for past failed
prediction theories so nailing the six
major villains for Peter peas next
outing in a movie that hasn't even been
announced yet would be tight over the
course of Marvel history there have been
over 40 members of the sinister six
which leaves us with a lot of villain
options to slot into the groups like the
popular frat of the comics everyone's
rushing to get in luckily I don't need
to rely on my usual prediction methods
there have been plenty of solid hints
sprinkled throughout the series if we
rewind back to homecoming by the end of
that film we've already met 50% of the
crew who will be heading up this new
version of the sinister six the first
and most obvious inclusion is Adrian
Toomes aka the vulture who may have been
kind enough to preserve Spidey's secret
identity in prison if I knew it was dead
but now that the whole world knows the
truth all bets are off
tooms has got himself an axe to grind
it's also worth noting that the vulture
is an OG member of the sinister six the
original seven iterations of this group
all featured the vulture prominently so
not including him when he's already an
established part of this Cinematic
Universe would be a big surprise and
that's not all vultures crew we have
ourselves a brief passing reference to
yet another classic spider-man villain
the shocker an MCU shocker isn't much of
a supervillain but instead he's just a
sucky salesman who fires off vultures
illegal Rockets in public and attracts
the attention of spider-man which in
turn makes vulture realize that old
Sparky is too much of a liability and
needs to be let go in the most violent
way possible well initially it looks
like vultures just turned the sinister
six into the fearsome five he quickly
replaces shocker with a new shocker
quite explicitly passing the torch I
don't think that's just a throwaway line
there friends it's brief and it's one
that's easy to write off as just a
tongue-in-cheek easter egg but remember
we saw a similar series of events become
the major plot twist and far from home
we're a bunch of smaller characters that
have been set up via past movies
suddenly emerged to the forefront to
become major players so the shocker
having a similar reveal in the third
spider-man movie oh yeah it is
definitely prescient in it and not only
that but shocker is indeed a canonical
member of the sinister six in the comics
I mean practically everyone is but still
he's there usually as a member of the
expanded Sinister's like the sinister
seven in the sinister 66 you heard that
right
66 or I thought infinity war had a lot
of characters so anyway that is two
villains right there in the first movie
but we can keep going there are a couple
or tertiary villains that we see running
in vultures crew but I'm more hesitant
to count on these guys because they
rarely appear in the sinister six and
they just don't have the same level of
name appeal specifically I'm referring
to the Prowler played in homecoming by
the childish gambino himself Donald
Glover and the tinkerer who is worth
mention because well if I didn't you
guys would light me up in the comments
thinking I missed him
I didn't he just isn't interesting
enough to make the official counted
squad here which then of course brings
us to the end of homecoming here the
vulture goes to prison and meets Mac
Gargan that name doesn't ring a bell the
tattoo on his neck certainly should a
scorpion looks like Mac is carrying on
the grand tradition of arthropods in
this franchise by taking the role of the
Scorpion a guy who traditionally has a
giant tail that shoots acid he'll the
more technology centric films will make
this attack strategy less awkward is up
for debate but there's no doubt that
he's gonna be joining forces with tooms
in just his brief scene alone it's
immediately established that he's also
after spider-man and wants to team up
so to recap have to start a far from
home we know that both these baddies are
still in prison together and the new
shocker is still floating around out
there somewhere too giving us a solid
lead on at least three out of six
Sinister's let's see who else is gonna
surface and far from home in the
beginning of the new movie Peter and his
friends just got themselves blipped out
of existence for five years by Thanos
the very fabric of reality has been
shaken whoopsy no worries the Avengers
figured out that pesky time-travel
business and now everything is back to
normal with everyone now completely
acclimated to aliens and magic and Tony
Stark destroying huge sections of major
cities it turns out to be the perfect
place for Mysterio to enter the fray
with the world willing to believe
literally anything at this point waiting
back in his organization of background
players from all the past movies decide
to create their own superhero a soldier
from another universe Mysterio and if
there was ever a superhero slash villain
perfect for the internet age this guy is
it he's fake he only does things for the
cloud his entire reputation depends on
everything being on video because if
there was indeed a true Avengers level
threat Mysterio would just be flat-out
useless in short Mysterio would just
make a great youtuber that would be
funny if it wasn't completely depressing
anyway
Hauk Mysterio up is another core member
of our new Sisterhood of the Traveling
Sinister's now I know the first thing
you're gonna say but we saw Mysterio die
at the end of far from home which yes is
absolutely true I totally think Quentin
Beck is dead despite my best efforts in
researching for this episode to prove
otherwise but and far from home where
very clearly shown a shot of his team
taking the computers and drives that
retain all of Mysterio's files I mean
think about it they were pulling the
Mysterio shtick before they got control
of Edith Edith just enabled him to do it
at a bigger scale and throughout the
movie they very intentionally show
Quentin Beck and Mysterio separately
Mysterio is just a projection a drone of
what this superhero suit looks like so
not only can Mysterio come back that
sort of plotline is also canon in the
source material Mysterio's original plot
in the early days of the spider-man
comics starting back in issue 13 is
pretending to be a good guy exposing
spider-man's true identity to Jay jonah
Jameson and then faking his own death
which wouldn't you know it all happened
to be the key beats we see him do and
far from home so we should consider
staying true to his comic book origins
and remember that he was also an OG alum
of the sinister six taking part in the
first five iterations of the group
taking a break for 6 & 7 and then coming
back strong in 8 & 10 meaning that
Mysterio is taking up our slot number 4
now from here our job gets a little
harder because we have to get two
villains that we haven't directly seen
yet but ones that I think the movies are
definitely setting us up for the first
open slot I think we'll take advantage
of Marvel's newest playthings the
scrawls
Captain Marvel was keen on showing off
the scrolls and how well they're able to
infiltrate the ranks of normal humans
but it was odd to see them also show up
and far from home a story they seem
pretty disconnected from why would
Marvel be showing us this now at this
point in the movies well I think it
boils down to two reasons both of which
go back to that inflection point I was
talking about at the beginning of the
episode first they know that spider-man
is and will always be their biggest hero
he's Marvel's equivalent of Batman I
mean sure Iron Man was big for the
movies but spider-man is
just iconic he was big before the Marvel
Cinematic Universe he was big before
Ironman really changed the superhero
scene so if the Skrulls are gonna play a
big role in the future of the MCU they
need to be introduced to mainstream
audiences who may not have seen Captain
Marvel through a more mainstream movie a
Spider Man so there's your reason one
but there is a second and more relevant
reason that applies to our theory today
you see there just so happens to be a
Spider Man villain with a very scroll
like power set the chameleon he's a
shapeshifter who's able to disguise
himself behind the face of whoever he
wants in fact the chameleon was Spider
Man's first ever villain introduced in
spider-man number one way back in 1963
and barring some fan theories he's never
actually appeared on the big screen
before which leaves the pathway totally
open to bringing him in via
shapeshifters that we already know exist
in this universe the scrolls so all you
would need to slot him into the
Sinister's is a scroll gone rogue one
with a chip on their scaly green
shoulder that's not just speculation we
may already have him identified many
fans believe they've already spotted
this guy in the MCU right here the guard
who sent to surveil Peter while he's in
Europe it's a small detail but his name
is Dimitri and wouldn't you know it but
that exact name Dimitri smear to Cobb is
the exact identity of the chameleon in
the comics give this man a pledge pin
ladies and gentlemen he is our number 5
which leaves us with one last slot to
fill and honestly if you go in any
number of really cool directions when it
comes to the spider-man movies thus far
the MCU has had a habit of tricking us
they know we know these stories and
characters that's what happens when a
hero gets rebooted so frequently in such
a short amount of time so to keep us
off-balance there to borrow a phrase
from the show that must not be named
subverting expectations they're
reinventing or reimagining the good and
bad guys in ways that we don't expect to
keep everything fresh and new Aunt May
is an old MJ doesn't stand for Mary Jane
and Peter's biggest bully flash isn't a
typical jock he's just an even bigger
nerd in much the same way there are
villains creeping around here that we
may not even see coming for example you
remember one of Peters relatively
unmemorable teachers back in homecoming
well her name
mrs. Warren which could be a name picked
totally at random or it could be that
she's a reimagined version of miles
Warren Peters biology professor starting
in spider-man 148 who ends up becoming
one of the sinister six villains The
Jackal a villain mind you who goes on to
clone Peter his dead girlfriend and his
dead parents in a plot line that wasn't
super well-received by comic fans but
still she's there and waiting to be
swiped right on so go ahead sinister six
take a chance
it's also been pointed out by others
that spider-man's been seen battling the
Manfredi crime family leading us to
believe that the comic book villains
Silvermane who's associated with that
family in the comics may also be
floating around along with a whole slew
of his accomplices there are plenty of
other Easter eggs like these and they
might materialize down the line but
here's the thing none of these guys are
cutting the mustard for me up until now
everyone we've talked about we've either
seen before like the stereo or vulture
or is just a backup player like shocker
or chameleon we need a big name we need
a major player the sinister six needs
its new lead singer its headliner
we need ourselves either Doc Ock or more
likely the Green Goblin and of the two I
think the Green Goblin is all set up and
ready to roll out not only is the Green
Goblin one of the most frequent members
of the sinister six but because the
Goblin is usually a member of the Osborn
family who are tech billionaires just
like Tony Stark
they tend to have ties to most of the
other villains in the comics and
likewise in the new cinematic universe
where technology is fueling a lot of
these characters powers they would have
connections in that realm to the Osborn
technology would help supplement what
the vulture is doing the Osborn
technology would help supplement the
Mysterio gang the Osborn technology
would help make the shocker stronger but
now let's go back to something I said
earlier about subverting expectations
remember flash the nerd bully he is very
clearly being set up for a future
plotline throughout the movie there's
this ongoing thread about his
relationship with his parents a weird
text message thread with them and that
one scene when they return home and he's
met by their driver in both scenes flash
is being ignored by his parents they're
absent they've forgotten about him it's
also clear that they have a very formal
relationship with flash having to call
them father and
it's very similar to the way that Harry
Osborn reacts with his father Norman
Osborn and most other spider-man stories
including the Sam Raimi movies theater
man traditional father Norman Osborn
Flash's family is also very rich as my
dad's car says just like The Osbournes
heck it's even been suggested that those
super-rich Osborne's are busy building
oscorp's new headquarters in the old
avengers building which you can see
being constructed in far from home but I
know what you're thinking he's Flash
Thompson he's not in Osborn and you know
what that's just what I thought too
that's what literally every fan wiki
online says but it seems like literally
everyone has been jumping to conclusions
here because at no point in the movies
do we ever hear Flash's last name he is
never once called Flash Thompson not
once he'd is always only flesh man even
right here in the credits he's only
listed as Flash Matt seriously you might
wanna that right there is our smoking
gun loyal theorists the big twist the
way our expectations are gonna end up
being subverted in the next spider-man
movie is that Flash's last name is gonna
be revealed as Osborn that's what I'm
building up a good flow here you're
throwing off my dramatic reveal well
here's a more dramatic reveal for you oh
yeah so it's not in the script or the
credits but yeah well why didn't you
tell me earlier because even if he is
Flash Thompson there's a very real
chance that he could have been just
adopted by the Osbourne's that sort of
angle would have support from the comics
in the story Norman Osborn takes flash
under his wing gives flash a job makes
him feel like part of the family and
ultimately turns him against spider-man
who he was formerly idolizing just like
we see flash idolizing spider-man in far
from home so there you have it friends
we got ourselves our six villains
vulture shocker scorpion chameleon
Mysterio and Green Goblin all set and
ready to go but to close things out here
I think I'll put myself even further out
on a limb I think it's worth pointing
out that there's one villain in this
group who
is different than all the others vulture
vulture is very clearly established to
be a family man I built this whole place
because I got people like to look at
he's not about world domination or being
a renowned superhero heck he doesn't
even want to attract the attention of
the Avengers if you bring damage control
party Avengers down here with he's not
in it for the cloud like Mysterio he's
not in it for revenge he's only in it to
take care of his wife and his daughter
the same daughter who's spider-man saved
at the end of homecoming and who then
went on to rescue vulture himself during
the final battle we already know that
vulture wouldn't give up Peter Parker's
identity to scorpion and we know he has
at least half a dozen opportunities to
finish him off during that final
confrontation and doesn't so when faced
with option of teaming up alongside a
bunch of villains who are bent on world
domination
well he might initially go along for the
ride it's my prediction that vulture
will instead defect to instead protect
someone who shares his values and goals
someone who still appreciates helping
out the little guy the local
neighborhood in the end vulture is gonna
be the one to end up protecting
spider-man against the rest of the
sinister six
anyway that is more than enough
speculation and fan fiction for the day
I mean I'm already trying to make calls
on a movie that hasn't even been
announced to exist yet let me slow my
roll a little here regardless of how it
all plays out I'm excited for this third
installment in spider-man franchise I
actually love these movies they're some
of my favorite in the MCU and whether
you agree or not I hope you like
watching and theorizing about where
things go next because it's a superhero
movie it's all just for fun just like
this is all just a theory ah film theory
and if you want to see more spider-man
content check out this video on the left
where I analyze the physics of
spider-man's deadly web slinging it
turns out that spider-man should have
died multiple times over regardless of
this super strike or while you're here
make sure you click the button on the
right to subscribe I've got an upcoming
theory on which spider-man would win in
a battle royale of spider-man make your
predictions now friends that theories
coming up in the near future and with
that I'm off next week let's take a
break from superheroes shall we